[Music]
we'll be talking about Arcane today so I
think I need a better Avatar that's a
little more
painterly much better don't judge me for
how I look being in a tube for 7 months
does that to you anyways let's talk
arcane's strange production
pipeline Studio fortish the French
Animation Studio that gave us Arcane
follows a fairly unique production pipel
line that they slowly reveal over the
course of their Bridging the rift
YouTube series however despite how
informative this series is on a large
chunk of their pipeline there's a lot of
information that gets left out here how
do they paint the light I cannot tell
you it's a little frustrating that they
gave us every step of the process except
for lighting the one thing I wanted to
learn but I suppose it's a tall order to
ask for the greatest animated series
ever released and public access to all
the technology that made it happen and
if time has told us anything it's going
to be another year or so before we get a
documentary Series so I did my research
the trick here is that there is no
lighting department there's barely a set
and there are no simulated effects what
you see on the screen in every scene of
Arcane is a set of unshaded 3D bottles
2D paintings and handdrawn visual
effects all tied together by the
mightiest set of compositing artists on
God's green earth it's a pipeline so
unique controllable and creatively
fulfilling that it only felt right for
me to lay it out in a cleaner way for
you to apply yourself without spending
thousands on software and employees this
video will cover each piece of arcane's
pipeline starting with the methods and
technology used by fortish followed by
how to recreate the effects with 100%
free software using this video as a
toolkit you should be able to create
anything just like Studio forti
beginning to end before we move on to my
Arcane knowledge I do have to keep the
lights on so allow me to fulfill a
contractual obligation this video is
sponsored by flexispot if you're an
artist like me you probably also spend a
good chunk of your day rotting in a
chair and for the longest time I was
rotting in this chair which is why
flexis spots C7 ergonomic chair has been
a total game Cher for me in office mode
the C7 back rest locks at 93° and
supports my back while the adjustable
headrest prevents my abnormally long
neck from taking any unnecessary strain
the breathable and highly elastic mesh
seat cushion allows me to work for
incredibly long hours without feeling
like I need to constantly get up and
readjust and if a foam cushion is more
your style don't worry they have that
too don't even get me started on the
lumbar support on this thing when I
first got a taste of that adaptable
lumbar support I tell you I cannot go
back no more cramming this giant plush
into my old chair to convince myself I
was making my back healthier besides
just being healthy the C7 is an
incredibly comfortable option the seat
on this thing is significantly larger
than other chair brands you can even
tilt it forward to circulate blood
through your legs speaking of gaming the
3D adjustable armrests make sure to
provide support to your arms no matter
where you game whether you're typing
drawing whatever you do in relaxed mode
the C7 quickly turns into a recliner
with a back rest that can lock into up
to four different positions and of
course a comfortable mesh foot rest a
feature that makes my workday infinitely
more relaxing and is somehow missing
from every other chair on the market if
you're worried about making a commitment
flexi spot offers a 30-day return policy
for a completely risk-free trial as well
as a 10-year warranty with direct
replacement for any damaged Parts if you
use my code c730 right now you can slice
$30 right off your order of the C7 share
and remember that if you don't like it
you can always return it I would never
promote a product to you guys that I
wasn't a fan of and this one has been a
total game changer for
[Music]
me one of the impressive Feats that
Arcane pulls off is not just being an
incredi looking show but also sporting a
very robust story with Incredible
cinematography and for that we have
script writing storyboarding and design
teams to thank for your story script to
your heart's content there really is no
Arcane style script do your best to cook
up something that you enjoy and maybe
watch some local script as for
storyboarding though there are some
things to keep in mind because fortish
is often compositing paintings directly
into the scene complex camera movements
need to be kept to a minimum save these
crazy sweeping rotating shots for your
best off-the-wall moments but other than
that keep your shots subdued with good
composition and simple camera movements
generally fortish approaches Arcane a
lot more like a film than an animation
these shots occupy real space in the
world and tend to shy away from
stretching proportion and throwing us
into impossible off-the-wall battles as
awesome as those are arcane's frame is
also 21 by9 so save yourself some
drawing time and cut out the top and
bottom of the frame as for doing it
ourselves I storyboard my scenes in
blender using grease pencil just open up
blender select the 2D animation
workspace and you're pretty much set to
draw whatever you want once you have
those images render them out and then
time them up to your audio of choice in
Da Vinci resolve or whatever editing
software you use on screen scen I have
the story board I've used for my own
project they're very simple and sloppy
but as a oneperson production you can
often take the liberty of leaving your
story boards vague and filling in those
gaps during your production in a real
production like Arcane we need to
effectively communicate every single
important character and Camera move as
many departments are going to have to
interpret our storyboard but when we're
working alone time is really the biggest
thing to worry about and trusting your
gut is often the solution to that now
that we have our storyboard it is time
for some character models
[Music]
models in Arcane are fairly standard but
differentiate themselves from other
Productions in very subtle but powerful
ways teaching you how to sculpt a
character from scratch would take far
too long for this tutorial but dicko the
guy who taught me how to model is
currently doing a series on character
sculpting and Ryan king art always cooks
with beginner tutorials on just about
any topic so I have both playlists
linked below arcane's models have a very
strong art style the core of these
models is their imperfections as the art
of Arcane States a big point in arcane's
modeling is imperfection old models had
very basic round eyes with circular
highlights we wanted to deal with
characters as if we had done a real
casting we wanted them to have a few
small flaws everything in Arcane has
flaws faces are not perfectly
symmetrical for example in Arcane there
is not a single object that is a perfect
Cube cone sphere or cylinder except for
the hex gemstones and this is 100%
intentional this law extends to just
about everything including character
eyes which often have small
imperfections and edges and while
they're often hard to notice it gives
everything a very handcrafted feel that
adds up more and more the more you fill
your scene with these objects overall
Arcane doesn't have special topology and
you're following a fairly standard
workflow and just letting the textures
do the heavy lifting but these
principles of design are what Drive the
looks while you're putting together
reference or drawing your characters
skew the design and exaggerate important
features it goes a long way when
creating assets ourselves characters
should start with a good sculpt in
blender sculpt mode and once again watch
some dicko watch some Ryan King and once
you have a retopologized model just
start skewing things around on my model
I took the head the cap the belt and
this little box on the head and I just
warped them enough to no longer be basic
Primitives that's it for modeling though
pretty straightforward for 3D artists
time to move on too
[Music]
as you could probably tell arcane's
models are hand painted and that is a
task that would 100% be easiest in a
program like substance painter but we
don't have that kind of money in this
house so I'll be showing you how to do
it in blender I'd recommend getting this
free brush pack I have linked below as
well as ucu painter before you begin
arcane's texture team loves Square
brushes and you'll often see a lot of
Blocky shading being applied with this
type of brush and frankly the layer
system in ucu paint should just be
default in Blender at this point for
reference without layers texturing this
model took 4 and 1/2 hours I'm confident
I could have done that in half the time
if I had more than one single layer to
work with use your resources kids for
the most part this is a standard job UV
unwrap your model as you normally do and
lay out your colors and just start
painting away the biggest thing here is
to keep your colors relatively subtle
you'll notice on Jinx here image Link in
the description it's a great resource
the value changes on the skin and
clothing are relatively tight when we
paint a static picture we usually want
to utilize strong contrast to avoid a
washed out looking image but these
models still have to go through a lot of
processing before the shots are finished
so feel free to use lighter values and
stray away from those dramatic shadows
and great changes in contrast I'd
imagine your character in a pretty
regular well-lit indoor area like a
grocery store that's the general value
range you're shooting for final thing to
keep in mind as you paint is to stray
away from the line tool for the most
part and try to keep things a little
messy it's very common for us digital
artists to keep things very clean but
the magic of painting is the quote
unquote mistake Bob Ross was not lying
when he calls them happy little
accidents wobbly lines and layered
Strokes add so much life to your bottle
so keep them intact and learn to love
them I know as a technical 3D artist we
often get a little obsessive over these
mathematically perfect Graphics but
fortish is not a fan of that other than
that best thing I can say is to try your
best and Trust the process I'm not a 2d
artist and certainly not a painter but
for a beginner I think this came out
pretty well it looks a little too much
like a fortnite skin but overall I am
quite happy with it and it only took
five entire hours damn you blender and
your one texture painting
layer now that we have our character
model and the storyboard we can dive
into what really sells the forti look
tangent time okay here's the deal after
models and story keyboards are created
just about every department at fortish
Works simultaneously to create each
scene 3D animators block the character
animations in the scene according to the
storyboard while 2D artists paint the
background behind the character
animations while layout artists are
taking those paintings and modeling in
the geometry which will eventually have
said painting projected onto it and used
in the final render the magic of forti's
workflow comes from the fact that none
of these mediums necessarily need to
interact with each other until the
compositing phase so everybody can kind
of craft their specific piece of the
scene and set it in the compositor lap
as an asset later all we really need are
solid passes of the 3D character
animation the background and the
textured objects from there forti's
compositing artists use a software like
Nuke to place all the passes together
and edit in all the lighting so it feels
like the characters are really there
that is the secret it is all a big 2D
illusion everyone does their individual
part and then compositor Jam all of
those puzzle pieces together into one
cohesive scene like I said no lighting
team barely a set no simulated effects
tangent over if you're working alone as
I imagine most of you are we have the
unique advantage of being able to
approach scene Creation in just about
any order we want but the unique
disadvantage of being individuals with
strengths and weaknesses if you're
naturally a 2d artist I'd personally
make paintings according to your
storyboard and then build your scene
scene and project the textures that
workflow is pretty much one to one with
what fortish does and if you're good
enough at painting often the only 3D
work you'll really need to be doing is
animation and that saves a ton of time
if you're naturally a 3D artist though I
build your scene with geometry first and
hand texture those finished sets like
you would on any other scene this is
what I personally did because I can't
paint yet the final thing before we move
on is exclusively for 2D artists and
that is camera projection it's quite
complicated but luckily lightning boy
Studios did one of the most in-depth
tutorials on it Link in the description
this will allow you to paint your scenes
while still retaining the 3D information
you can use for Parallax and custom
lighting later I find a lot of tutorials
overstate the importance of this step if
your paintings are convincing enough you
can foro projection entirely and just
use the painting like this shot for
example which is pretty much all 2D but
if you want a dynamic camera or more
control give projection a shot it will
serve you well as for myself you can see
me simply going through my scene
unwrapping everything before texture
painting all of the light and detail the
goal of painting like this is to
effectively have a finished painting in
your 3D scene light and all because
Arcane doesn't use traditional 3D
Lighting on its characters the
compositing team uses the light that the
2D artists painted in to drive the
custom Lighting on the character if you
don't have 2D experience you might find
the step quite difficult as did I the
the best advice I can give is just stick
to that square brush and try using a
lower opacity to add some chaos to your
textures a lot of these assets have big
blotches of unique color added to them
just to increase the visual charm and
mimic a real world canvas that gets
layered over time once you have
everything blocked I like to go in with
a soft brush and paint in some of the
light like this green light coming from
this giant tube trust the process here
and stick to the Arcane design rules and
I promise whatever you create will look
great honestly this was my longest step
clocking in at about 14 hours but that
is the price of hand painting and why
this show costs $ 250
million you can do it I believe in
you oh boy after all that we arrive at
the fun part animation first things
first frame rate should be 24 frames a
second animation in Arcane generally
finds a happy middle ground between the
hyper exaggerated movement of a car
cartoon and the grounded movement of a
liveaction film we still have Snappy
stylized motions smears duplicates all
of that but characters generally obey
the laws of physics each movement from
regular facial acting to a high-speed
punch is preceded by proper anticipation
and generally even the fantasy weapons
bionic parts and machines all function
within the laws of the real world
continue to use the principles of
animation and just make them invisible
enough that it doesn't break your own
immersion and a great way to make sure
you're always on mod model is to act out
the scenes yourself I know in the
beginning of my animation career I was
quite camera shy even though the footage
wasn't going to be public it can be a
little cringe watching yourself act like
a cartoon character on camera but trust
me this is the only way to capture the
incredibly complex workings of the human
body in fact Riot has an entire room
dedicated just to animation reference
with mirrors to correctly capture the
action from multiple angles and props so
the animators can correctly represent
the weight of the objects in their scene
it's genuinely so awesome the lengths
Arcane animators go to capture reference
even acting out the scenes together like
in this clip it it's just so rad do this
and do this a lot here for this hand
animation I really did just set up my
camera and act out the motion and with
that information I was able to block out
the important poses and once I converted
my constant key frames to bezier ones it
looked pretty on point with some
tweaking it's a real world accurate arm
animation with no smears while still
being Snappy and satisfying this is the
core of arcane's style use tons of
reference and your scenes will
practically animate themselves other
than that standard
[Music]
animation final thing we need to do
before we reach the Behemoth that is
compositing is to compile all of our
Assets in one place in this case it's 2D
effects and properly rendering our
animation with passes which is much more
important than you probably think there
is nothing fortish special about this
process so here's a rundown on how to do
everything properly let's tackle the 2D
effects first blender's Grease pencil
really is the perfect tool for this as
you can just draw directly on the camera
and render that as its own object
personally I like to place a plane right
in front of the camera by selecting the
camera pressing shift s and then cursor
to select it adding a plane rotating at
90° to match the camera and then paring
that plane to the camera and giving it a
transparent materi material like so from
there if you set the grease pencil to
draw on a surface it will draw right on
top of the camera so you can create
frame by frame animation little dust
clouds stuff like that do remember that
to save time fortish animates 2D effects
at 12 FPS half the frame rate of the 3D
animation so only place your key frames
on every second frame in your timeline
now that we have our animation
background and effects it's time for a
crash course in professional exporting
first off the PNG was in invented in
1997 we don't need it anymore set your
render format to open exr multi-layer
and set the float to half and the Codex
to dwaa and then come to your render
passes and enable all of the options
under data this will render our scene as
an exr instead of a PNG file not only
does exr take up less than half the
space on your disc compared to a PNG but
the exr comes with a ton of crazy
features it automatically stores your
render as an HDR or a high dynamic range
image meaning that it basically saves
your image at just about every exposure
level and packs all of those into one
file a PNG will hardcode every pixel to
be a certain color meaning that the Pure
White Center of a flame is going to
remain white no matter how high or low I
set my exposure more importantly though
exr saves multiple passes of your render
inside of the image including normal and
position data which we can later use in
our compositing software to create
effects and relight our scene which as
we know is a core component of the
Arcane workflow next thing we do is come
to color management override and set our
color space to Aces CG this one is
complicated so buckle up in short for
those of you who don't even want to
approach this topic we render like this
because it gives us a lot of color
control and it pairs well with the exr
format in Vinci resolve for those of you
who want to know prepare yourself this
triangle represents the colors we can
see this triangle represents what we
call the srgb color space which is what
our monitors and TVs can display it's a
whole lot less color than our eyes can
comprehend but it's the most available
technology so it is everywhere and most
of the time it looks fine and gets the
job done however as technology
progresses displays evolve and now we
have HDR TVs that can display brighter
highlights and darker shadows and the
ever evolving movie theater projector
has access to even more colors than a
monitor or a TV for a more immersive
experience so when creating a cool piece
of art that we want to last we render in
Aces which stores just about every color
we can possibly get our hands on while
it looks quite ugly on our screens it's
because our screens aren't built for it
it's great for archival and it's great
for working with because we have access
to so much more color data to both work
with in the future and the present it's
so commonplace now that in fact there's
a node in da Vinci excl exclusively to
correct Aces back to srgb just for you
all in all we are storing our image like
this so that in the future we can use it
on better displays and in the present we
can use it to color grade if you don't
get that or you want more there's a
billion videos on Aces out there and you
should go watch them when we finally
render our animation we will get all of
these passes neatly laid out with
everything ready to be composited and
all of that normal data packed into the
exr file
[Music]
all right time for the big one buckle up
Arcane as well as just about every show
in movie you see nowadays is composited
in the program nuke not after effects
not da Vinci resolve nuke there is a
very good reason for it despite its
quite outdated looking interface nuke is
a juggernaut of a program there are
nodes that reconstruct your scene in 3D
based on position data and incredible 3D
tools made for relighting track able
mats for 3D objects everything you could
ever want nuke is the backbone of
arcane's compositing as the relighting
tools it provides are the foundation for
just about every scene forti's goal here
is creative control and being able to
control the color grade composite and
lighting All in One Singular program is
what makes Arcane such a good-looking
show arcane's compositing pipeline gives
you the control of a painter or a
charcoal artist where you're constantly
creating chaos in your scene and then
adding and subtracting new information
until you arrive at a product that may
not be realistic but has a very strong
focused art Direction and looks
absolutely stunning while 2D lighting is
based on a very human view of how light
works 3D lighting is mathematically
perfect and can often appear clinical
and unappealing if not treated with care
that's why CG in anime often feel so
uncanny it is literally perfect there
are ways that it can work and it often
requires you to embrace 3D as a medium
which is the correct Avenue be Stars
land of the lustrous and triy gun
Stampede look absolutely Rad but the
moment you try blending these perfect 3D
assets with an imperfect 2D environment
things get messy and you start teetering
on the edge of unintentional mixed media
arcane's solution of Leaning into the 3D
exclusively for animation is nothing
short of genius and it's what makes the
art feel so incredibly cohesive the
coolest thing is that a non-commercial
version of nuke is completely free with
the the only major limitations being a
maximum render resolution of 1080P and
obviously it's non-commercial so no
monetized YouTube videos I'm guessing a
lot of you are planning to post your
animations as YouTube videos though and
nuke literally costs $3,000 a year so
today I will be showing you how to use
Da Vinci resolve for this if you have a
method of acquiring nuke do it it is
worth every penny and the overall
principles I teach here will be the same
but for us brokies let's do it in divid
compositing is a long and complicated
process that many of you may be
unfamiliar with as 3D artists so for
simplicity's sake I will be compositing
this cute little Minecraft animation
into this painting I found on Riot's
website the first thing we want to do is
to get our footage into the compositor
and to do this we will use the loader
node simply add the node select the
first image in your exr sequence and
voila the reason we use a loader node
instead of a media in is that the loader
node is a lot less intense on our
machine and from what I've heard media
in actually handles footage very poorly
so loader node always on top always
you'll notice that our footage looks
awfully different compared to when we
created it and that is because of our
AC's CG color space that I mentioned
earlier to fix it place an Aces
transform node in front of any Aces
footage set your Source color space to
Aces CG and set the output to either
srgb or Rec 709 depending on your
monitor just give both both a try and
whichever looks correct you can keep now
that we have this in here it is time for
the exr magic come to file extend this
drop down on your footage and come to
the normal XYZ area so long as you
enabled the normal pass you should have
a view layer do normal in each of these
drop downs so match up the normal X Y
and Z to their respective panel and now
the magic can
begin if you add a Shader node Da Vinci
is now effectively shading your model
with a 3D light in 2D it's a far cry
from nuke's entire custom 3D workspace
with position data but we make do using
this data you can not only light your
entire model but also adjust how they're
ambiently lit when they're not in harsh
daylight and if you want you can even
turn down the ambient light all the way
and use this black and white image as a
mask for other effects in my Minecraft
scene I add both a Shader node for the
white light hitting the model as well as
a second Shader node for this orange
light that I blurred out in composite
did over my scene the other lighting
trick I've used is taking my background
painting blurring it and compositing it
over the whole scene using a merge node
set to screen it gives all the
highlights a really nice warm glow and
places some of that color information on
the character as they walk from right to
left finally the most important thing to
do is duplicate your background image
and use the polygon tool to mask out any
foreground objects you want in front of
your character like this table for
example once we have these elements the
shot is pretty much ready to ship unless
we want to go above and beyond and add
some special detail in my case I
duplicated the animation distorted it
and multiplied it over the floor to
create this fake reflection I also
rendered the foreground separately and
had it move a little faster than the
background to create a parallax when I
was done I took the whole scene and key
framed it to slowly move to the side as
if we have a big sweeping camera in
Vinci there is so much you can choose to
do too much to even cover in a video but
that's the magic of this workflow the
possibilities are literally infinite and
you have total control over what the
final product looks like in your Fusion
space if I wanted to right now I could
throw a color grade onto my painting add
some effects and then change the
direction of the lighting and all of a
sudden I have a big green glow coming
from the inside of the room the fact
that we can do all of this with just a
3D render and a painting is incredible
but it really is just the ultimate way
to use all the technology you have
around you to create a product that
looks cool and also is easy to put
together in compositing software once
you're done with this composite just
throw in some regular old sound effects
and that's it the ever elusive Arcane
workflow laid out bare for all to gaze
upon I think this looks quite nice only
time will tell whether for T will
release this first or we will find a
onetoone match ourselves but I'm excited
to see what the future holds for this
workflow and I have absolutely fallen in
love with it thank you to my four
wonderful active patrons nocan jizzer
Gil and for
for keeping food on this poor starving
artist's table once again thank you to
flexi spot for sponsoring my video make
sure to use this totally 6 c730 code and
try out that 30-day free trial to see if
the C7 share is right for you I will see
you in the next one probably not a
tutorial but the next one